-Welcome back to the show.
I appreciate you coming on.
-I'm so happy
to be here in person.
-Yeah.
-It's like wearing a suit
and, like, hard clothing.
It's actually so nice.
It doesn't sound like it
would be, but it really is.
-Yeah, you're not Zooming.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-You look great, by the way.
I like that suit.
-Thanks. You too.
-I want to congratulate
you on --
You just won an Emmy like
yesterday or the day before.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Queer Eye."
Congratulations!
-And what's so exciting is,
it's really an award for --
'Cause it was
Best Unscripted Series,
so it's really, like -- It's
an award for everybody, right?
It's like every single person
of production
really got to, like, enjoy it,
which is really nice.
-It's so well-done.
-Four years running,
which is, like, crazy.
-It really is, right?
Congrats on that.
You have all sorts of
good tips in this book.
Just looking at
some of these photos,
you go, "Oh, my gosh."
I would just eat every single
thing in this here.
Oh, my God. It's so good.
I just, like --
-Thank you.
-I gain 20 pounds just by
looking at it, but --
-But it's all healthy-ish.
-It is healthy, by the way.
-Most of it.
-But what is the --
What's the reason for --
This is your second cookbook.
The first one was just recipes
that you learned growing up?
-Pretty much. Like, I think --
-I have that one, as well.
-"Antoni in the Kitchen"
was basically like
a culinary memoir of,
like, dishes that shaped me,
my Polish heritage,
dishes that didn't make it
on to "Queer Eye"
that I was a little salty about,
so I wanted to throw them
into a book.
-That's right.
-And with "Let's Do Dinner,"
it's really --
You know, the irony of the life
that I have now is,
I don't -- pandemic aside,
I don't have as much time
in the kitchen,
but I still want to have
meaningful, good food,
but I just don't have
as much time to make it.
So this book is
a reflection of that.
-I follow you on
all the socials and stuff.
You know I'm a big fan of you.
-Ditto.
-And I saw a lot of bookstores
really getting behind you
and supporting
"Let's Do Dinner."
And this one bookstore --
I guess you sent out
cardboard cutouts of you
to these --
-Okay, I need to clarify.
I did not send out
life-size cutouts of myself.
-Yeah, but someone must have.
-The publisher.
-Alright, well --
-My publisher decided it was a
thing that was going to happen,
and I went with it
because I'm Canadian,
and we're not combative
and we just, like --
We just say -- We "Yes and..."
-Yes and...
Obviously.
But this is at
the Blue Willow Bookshop
in Houston, Texas.
This is you hanging out with --
in front the bookstore there.
-I remember that day
with great fondness.
-Yeah, you were outside all day.
-I showed up with
my smoked-trout Nicoise
and perfect jammy eggs
in a mohair sweater and jeans
and I just waited outside
of Blue Willow Bookshop.
-Yeah. And then --
-As one does.
-And then here's you at the
Country Bookshop in
Bozeman, Montana.
-Oh, that was my two friends.
-Yeah. You remember meeting
them, as well?
-I really remember, yeah.
-Well, I was thinking, why --
It's fun to just have
one Antoni here, but why not
have two Antonis out here?
I thought if we have --
Do we have the other Antoni?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
There you are. Here.
How does it compare to
the real -- Can you --
I mean, it's really legit.
It's real. It's bizarre.
-It's terrifying.
-No, it is not.
-There's nothing
natural about it.
-No, I was wondering,
would you like to autograph it,
and maybe we'll give it
to a fan?
Anyone --
-I would love to.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Do I sign on my chest?
-Yeah, exactly.
♪♪
Alright, here we go. Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here you are. Let's go.
Bring it to somebody?
-Bringing it?
-Yeah.
-Alright.
-Who wants Antoni?
[ Crowd cheering ]
Here we go. Do you see one?
Do you know where it's going?
Here.
-It's for you.
Good luck!
-Look at that.
Good luck getting it home.
Good luck.
-I'll get you an Uber.
I'll get you an Uber.
-I was gonna say, good luck
getting that on the subway.
Guys, the book
is "Let's Do Dinner."
Antoni Porowski, everybody.
-Thank you.